quelques 290 7000 élèves ont fait leur
rentrée ce mardi matin dans les yvelines
plus d'un million dans l'ensemble de
l'académie de versailles
des effectifs en légère hausse par
rapport à l'an dernier
la progression la plus significative est
à chercher dans le premier degré pour
accueillir ces élèves on annonce du côté
du rectorat des moyens en hausse 100
postes de professeurs des écoles
supplémentaires dans l'académie 22 pour
le seul département des yvelines
toujours dans les yvelines en compte 40
emploi d'assistant d'éducation en plus
ces postes dédiés à la vie scolaire et
d'ici à la fin 2012 des assistants
chargés de prévention et de sécurité des
aps vont aussi être recrutés sur la
volonté du nouveau gouvernement et
seront 500 en france 46 dans les quatre
départements de l'académie à ceux
chargés d'agir contre les violences
enfin un dernier chiffre l'académie
emplois cette année 90 1923 personnes
dont plus de trente neuf mille
enseignants en collèges et lycées